hi guys I'm here with Harley from Epic
Meal Time today we are playing a game
that is based on a challenge that exists
on YouTube called the what's in my mouth
challenge where people blindfold each
other and put something in someone
else's mouth and they have to guess what
it is but we have a spin on that and
today we're playing the what's up my
butt challenge one at a time Harley and
I will blindfold each other we have
seven household items random in each bag
we don't even know what's in our own bag
I didn't even know this was happening
like I knew a boy goes like oh my god on
your but also yeah grab this mysterious
butt bag yeah we will choose something
from our bag that the other person has
to sit on and then try to guess what
that item is I feel like because I made
you do this
I'll go first yeah but first yeah you
can drive up first but I feel like we
should each look in our bags first and
kind of assess ss what the ghost of
Hannah Hart does everybody some of these
aren't good like for a but like I don't
want to be mean but like I want to
choose the ones that would be the worst
for your butt right this is bad for your
butt I hate that I came up with this
game to prepare your butt yeah I like
this like I don't know slow literally my
butthole just sewed itself up now the
worst challenge I've ever done on
YouTube oh my god there it is oh my god
I might legs are like shaking right now
what okay
hmm did I break it break it it's okay
something sounded like a crack do you
would you feel ah uh got something sharp
there don't poke there is a place deep
there's a pond what are you feel I feel
like something in my butt crack right
now it felt like a pointy and there that
it's like a beer bottle opener
you're so stupid oh hey guys putting
this up on eBay proceeds go to charity
I'll just go this is I feel like I'm
being very fair and starting very what I
gave you was like the nicest thing I had
in my bag I keep thinking it's a kitchen
knife
oh nothing will hurt you here I know I
dance it's so weird with this document
or something
do you feel it am I sitting on it yeah I
know I noticed okay it's at the center
of my bug where I could kind of feel
more you might have just fragile yeah
this is a spoon are you kidding me is it
actually knows what move feels like look
up I am donar vez it's on the chair and
I have the utmost faith in your in your
faith in your butt Oh God okay what okay
get your hand out of there I'm not just
moving my sweater I trying are you right
um I'm gonna say I'm gonna say keys oh
these are a lock like this in their
house right now you do great now because
you that belongs to you now
I did such a strange strange feelin that
there's something there for you but oh
okay I just make a phone call
yes this is the phone just turned it on
but not the thing you want on your butt
ever people would people have this in
their but must I must
okay you think that it would get easier
every time maybe like less afraid but if
it does it okay like it could be
anything
yes what did you about to wait that
feels different you're learning
something there's something about it
that you couldn't take from this no move
move the thing like this see you're
learning something I'm learning about
hey this is the next Karate Kid movie is
this no idea I'm gonna say a key chain
yeah so many pores are not household
items
my butt is ready okay good just placing
it is in place and ready to accept your
but it's not a knife no it's not
you think you're a horse counting right
now doing something I actually cannot
feel it I know how I look now you have
to guess there's there's nothing is
there nothing okay there's something on
my eyes it's tough not to like balls is
necklace die obviously dice just do this
is what I'm trying to decide between
mother which one which one people at
home to know I feel like that's easy I
feel like this is easy but this one too
and now I'm going to be a gentleman and
put this object here for your blood
the dynamic of the chair is messing with
this one I'm gonna I'm an audible what
was it I'll find out after no it was a
ruler oh you're actually just like an
old woman like about the pig so slowly
sitting
almost people shaking in the street
right now every single one feels exactly
the same I'm not your problem
yeah stop therapy says you know now I'm
just trying to break it yeah get it get
it girl where is video it's a comb he's
there I have combs my beard with this
book ah what is it
Oh pork you couldn't put it in this way
at least I could at least well I was
trying to be safe for you this feels
like way too obvious yeah I'm not gonna
do that give me a challenge that might
also be very obvious this I'm curious
about so I think my curiosity is gonna
be the one that chooses so my curious I
like if I can get it or not or curious
as to like what might happen when your
butt touches it I almost just fell
forward oh oh uh uh no just went rape
alright butthole can I borrow your chair
for a second yeah you take the chair
this is actually free style what is in
my butt now oh my god that's cheating a
little bit isn't it that's okay now you
have to guess it's a baby shoe baby it's
over here a harmonica I was really
hoping that you might like fart while
you're sitting on it and I'm not making
I thought of it so good and you guys I
would be so upset I cannot thank you
enough
yeah fighting me to this and having me
be part of this I've really feel special
yeah I love when all of my guests leave
with a sense of anxiety and distress and
the sore butt in a sword but thank you
for participating Harley go check out
Epic Meal Time
and Harley more and then Harley plays on
every other social media platform yeah
follow me on snapchat Harley plays it's
really hilarious you say [ __ ] I really
good and if you want to listen to the
full interview of the podcast go to
SoundCloud comm slash not too deep with
grace and check it out I don't know how
much money would you have to get paid if
any to name your first child taint